in this morning's ion money a new survey
shows many older Americans are taking
steps to prepare for retirement but a
majority might not be ready for the
financial long haul 74% of survey
respondents age 60 to 75 failed a quiz
about making their savings last through
retirement CBS News business analyst
Jill Schlesinger is here with some
savings tips and reminders good morning
good morning I know we mentioned that
quiz but let's start with people in
their 20s and 30s retirement planning
usually not a top priority what should
they be doing yeah I mean I know that
it's really hard to focus on this but
you know you're becoming a financial
adult you want to start tracking where
your money is going coming in going out
and one of the things that can be really
useful is to at least know what that
money where that money is going so that
you can focus on paying down that
student loan debt I know that's a huge
issue for lots of people if possible
we'd love to get you in the habit of
saving especially if you're working for
a company that has a matching component
to their retirement plan 5% 6% that
would be totally fantastic while you're
juggling your other responsibilities so
save and what else well I think that the
most important thing when you're really
young is to get into this habit and
paying attention to it as you go into
your 30s right this is a time where
maybe your real life is entering the
universe right you're saying maybe I'm
coupling off or maybe I'm single and
making enough money and I can start
really thinking about what kind of goals
and objectives I have prime age you say
35 to 50 years old 35 to 50 is huge I
mean I just want to be clear that you
know when we talk about 6% versus say
you know 10 15 % later the earlier you
start the better I just want to put this
out there you're 25 years old you save a
hundred bucks a month right just a
hundred bucks a month I know it's hard
and you do that until you're 65 you're
going to have over 260 grand you do that
same exact calculation at age 45 for 20
years you're only going to have 52
thousand dollars that is the power of
compounding that's why we want you to
start early so let's go from 50 through
the mid-60s I think this is an important
time you know we go from 6% to maybe 10
tene 20% but when you're in your 50s and
60s hopefully the kids are gone this is
a critical time hopefully they'll be
back for a while but you know what this
is a time where you might be able to
catch up maybe you couldn't do as much
previously this is also a time to get on
track with what you and your partner
want to do in retirement and you know
maybe it's your estate planning your
life insurance I think it is so
important to remember that this is the
time also that you are focusing on what
you guys think about retirement more
people go out do more research about
buying a car than their own retirement
60 to 75 don't spend too much money when
you retire early on and don't forget as
you get to be 70 and a half that is the
time where the government forces you to
take money out of your retirement
accounts okay and if you're still
working at a company you don't have to
do so but that is critically important
you get a penalty for not taking money
out of those retirement thanks to thank
you